yes I'm still a committed brexiteer now
what I'm not going to say is that brexit
has been absolutely perfect there have
been challenges but that is what happens
when the plan is not in place before the
vote there should have been a plan in
place so that people knew what leave was
when I was Voting I wasn't an MP and I
just assumed oh there'll be a plan and I
got into parliament in 2017 there's no
plan so we spent three years just going
round and round in circles I didn't
expect that and I think we did let Lee
voters down and so I see it as a
personal mission that we have to show
that there can be a plan there is a plan
in place now it is working you know you
talked about the India FTA we're doing
loads of interesting things with our
independent trade policy like joining
the transpacific partnership that's
creating new rules of origin export
markets for us in a growing region so it
is working